this is your reminder that the BBC has
yet to address the consistent
transphobic leanings in its news
coverage and while the team behind
Doctor Who is not connected to this in
any way since this is a BBC owned
property I'm going to keep pointing it
out until the problem gets resolved
links in a pin comment below if you
don't know what I'm talking about I'll
stop saying it when it stops being a
problem I can't help but think I was a
bit foolish to think that just because
we're several months away from new
Doctor Who episodes I wouldn't have to
deal with breaking news
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so over the weekend the news
broke that Millie Gibson uh will be
leaving the show after her first uh full
series which is the
upcoming um series 14 SL season 41
season 1 depending on how you want to
count it
and yeah I didn't jump on this faster
for a couple of reasons uh the first is
it broke over the weekend I am trying in
some way to have a life so that was one
reason not to jump on it but actually
there was a fun and well not fun but
helpful side effect at least for me with
regards to that which is the fact that
it initially broke in the Daily Mirror
and did its first big round of being
spread through UK tabloids which look
they're not always wrong but they're um
definitely not always right and
especially with the tone of this
particular uh coverage which is
something I'm going to bring up in a
little bit uh I really wanted to wait
until a outlet I felt more comfortable
relying on confirmed it independently
and that has happened variety which
whatever you think about their coverage
of anything is pretty reliable about
confirming stuff or at least being clear
when something is or is not been
confirmed by them did confirm that not
only is Millie Gibson leaving she will
be appearing in several episodes in uh
the season after the upcoming one so
season
21542 um but uh the main companion is
going to be verata sethu so this here's
what I'm not going to do I am not going
to be speculating very much on the
reason for this there'll be a little bit
tangental speculation basically about
whether or not this was something
planned in advance I do have my thoughts
on that but like a core reason as to why
which is the kind of stuff that has been
speculated wildly both by certain
Outlets prone to speculation as well as
fans that I won't be getting into I've
seen people get into arguments over
whether she was some kind of a diva
whether she did something to tick
somebody off and like it the the tone of
the coverage especially from the the um
tabloids over in the UK like they're
using terms like dropped from and axed
and since they're tabloids any
subsequent stuff that they've run about
Millie Gibson because she's a celebrity
and they'll just run like she wore a
bikini is a story for some reason and
they'll also mention again how she was
dropped from it and like there's also
been a thing of shuyu breaks his silence
and shows support which I'll deal with
that too if only to show what a weird
kind of headline and perspective that is
to take for what was actually put out
but okay let's deal with the raw facts
as Bare Bones as I can while there has
not been anofficial statement as yet by
um badwolf Productions or RTD or
anything of that
nature Outlets with some degree of
credibility have confirmed Millie Gibson
is leaving verat sethu is coming in so
the most interesting aspect of this to
me is that Millie Gibson has I believe
it's three episodes that she's going to
be doing in the series after the
upcoming one now that would seem to
indicate to me that this was not an exit
plan for from the beginning and here's
sort of My overall thoughts on that it
would not at all be unusual for her to
just be a one season companion that
happens a fair bit both in classic and
in modern but to just stick with modern
Martha was a one-season companion Donna
was a one-season companion bill was a
one-season companion Dan was a
one-season companion it happens it's not
that unusual the only thing that's
unusual about it in this case is because
they are all already filming the next
season we are learning about it a lot
earlier than we might have otherwise
under normal circumstances if they
weren't shooting the next season until
at least the current one was starting
airing or possibly had even finished we
wouldn't be finding this out for a
little bit so I think part of what's
throwing things off is we are finding
out about it before the season she is
going to be the main companion in has
even aired and I've seen some people
Express like frustration like why are we
finding out about this again keep in
mind there is no official statement this
was not something that the um production
wanted known this is something that got
leaked or found out which is
unfortunately something that is more
prone to happen while stuff is filming
it's a lot harder to keep stuff under
wraps these days while it's filming
unless you are in a completely lock down
set which something like doctor who
doesn't really have the budget to do
like things like Marvel can do that cuz
you're shooting 90% of it on green
screen and yeah you can lock that down
but Doctor Who has never really been
great at that so I think people in
general fans and observers are blowing
it a little bit out of proportion just
because of how much earlier we're
learning it but the timing of us
learning that is not super unexpected
given that they are already filming the
next season now coming back to what I
started with while it's not unusual for
there to be only a one season long
companion and it's also not unusual for
a one season long companion to have
later appearances again Martha Donna Dan
they appeared after their one proper
season on the show it is a little bit
odd to have it dovetail into the start
of the next season but not for them not
to stick around for the whole thing that
is a little more unusual the closest
thing we've ever had to this was Series
7 which had Amy and Rory in the first
half and then clar in the second half
but that also had a very clean break
they deliberately at the planning stage
Cut That season in two to the point that
there was actually a holiday special in
between each half so that's still not
really quite the same thing so that is
why it kind of leads me to believe that
I don't think that Millie Gibson was
planned as a one season companion
because I would think now this is this
is the one bit of speculation I'm going
to get into I would think if you're
intending to only have her for as one
season you wrap up her story in that
season having her appear in three
episodes of The Following season feels
like the kind of thing you do when
someone has left earlier than you wanted
but is still willing to work with you so
you do the things necessary to wrap up
their story that wasn't wrapped up in
the season that they are the main
co-star that just makes logical sense to
me now
again a lot of people could go a lot of
directions about speculations as to why
or why not and look yes it could be
something scandalous but it could also
be something as simple as she got
whatever she wanted out of the
experience or she realized that the
schedule and possibly even the publicity
push push was more than she was going to
be willing to do for an ongoing basis
like this is a big commitment this is an
internationally aired show it's a lot so
there are all sorts of reasons and also
I'll point out there are companions who
also flip-flop back and forth and change
their mind at the last minute generally
it was in the opposite direction cuz
here I'm referring to claraa um and the
fact that Clara was set up to be able to
exit a couple of times before she
actually did because Jenna Coleman kept
saying I think I'm done and then
changing her mind so if we just think of
this as again I don't know this for
certain but just at least
philosophically Jenna colan in Reverse
someone who thought they were going to
do another season then going I I
actually I don't think that this this is
what I want to be doing and then they
just wrap the fact that she's getting
three more episodes to me says whatever
the cause it feels amicable cuz if it
wasn't she wouldn't come back like there
have been there have been some harsh
breaks in Doctor Who modern era
Christopher Eon the big one he has never
come back to appear on the show proper
he does some big finish stuff now and
it's very good but he has never come
back heck go back to Classic Colin Baker
who was replaced by Sylvester McCoy
refused to come back to shoot his
regeneration scene and frankly given the
way he was treated at the time I don't
blame him so so coming back and shooting
three more episodes to me feels like
what you do in an amicable split that
just happened a little bit earlier than
you thought it would have but that's the
amount of speculation I'm prepared to go
with so let's talk about the new actor
coming in verat sethu who I know from a
couple of things primarily Andor and I
like I like her presence she obviously
has genre experience not just in sci-fi
but in you know internationally known um
properties so I I think it'll it will be
an interesting fit there is sort of the
fact that this will result in the first
time there has been a Taris Team without
a white person and I suspect some people
are absolutely going to lose their over
that fact I will not be indulging those
people uh either in my words or in my
comments I know they exist that's about
as far as I want to go with that but um
the other thing that to me is kind of
interesting is that she's the same age
as shudy gatwa and while I know
narratively within the confines of the
show the doctor is far older obviously
but I did notice that gatwa brought a
very youthful energy to the part um and
that is something that will be
interesting that if he at least in terms
of how he plays it is bringing the
energy that coincides with his actual
age as a person then it would be
interesting to see that paired with
someone who is that same age and might
be able to relate to him in a way that
we don't often see the majority of
companions especially in the modern era
have been at least 5 years or more
younger than the doctor at least when
there's only been one companion things
got a little mix when you bring in say
Graham or Dan into the mix but they are
also part of a larger team so that
Dynamic is not getting as much Focus
Katherine Tate was a couple of years
older than David Tennant and I actually
do think that that lent a different
energy to their interactions
because while uh Vera sethu is well
she's certainly younger than me I I'm
not sure she counts as Hollywood young
uh the way that someone like Millie
Gibson uh does she is um certainly
generally young in the grand scope of
life experience and she is also I feel
at least a fairly attractive person this
doesn't feel like it's slots into quite
as much of the template that I'm kind of
tired of with uh with modern aerod Dru
especially which is Young uh
attractive
modernday UK um woman companion like I
I'd like to see more of that template
broke with the actual primary companion
like the few breaks that we've had have
been either shortlived or as part of an
overall team again uh when we've had uh
men as companions there have also been
women as companions at the same time
when we've had older ones there were
also younger ones in the at the same
time so the the General Dynamic of the
two person teams the doctor and one
companion has been older doctor younger
companion with the exception being
Katherine Tate now the difference in age
range has varied of course but having
them be the same age I just think it
brings the opportunity for a different
Dynamic and honestly with that four-part
template Young young attractive modern
era woman honestly anytime they break
any one of those four is a little bit of
a relief for me I'd like to see more of
those things broken more often but if at
the very least they're not fitting that
template completely on all four points
that's something I'll take it now am I
like super excited for this I mean no
I'm also not super disappointed for this
I haven't seen enough of Millie Gibson
as Ruby Sunday to know whether or not
I'm going to miss her and be left
wishing she had more maybe I will maybe
I won't I can't judge that off of a
single special um as for shy gowa I
alluded to earlier some Outlets have
been like breaks his silence and shows
support for Millie Gibson he put out an
Instagram story that was this and while
I don't think calling it support for
Millie Gibson is
inaccurate having this be the basis of
an article and to say that this is
breaking his silence when it was like a
day after the news uh broke that she was
not going to be sticking around uh as
the regular companion passed the first
season like it's it's him going like I
like her in emojis like
what
tabloids tabloids are the drama YouTube
of print journalism well it's not even
all print a lot of it's digital but like
it's it's that same level of anything
that they can milk enough words out of
just like how drama YouTube is anything
I can milk at least eight minutes out of
so that I can get mid roll ads yeah same
principle so like I'll acknowledge
that's the thing he put out and again I
don't think it's a lie to say that it is
showing his support for her but
like that's that's
nothing whatever but but yeah overall I
don't think this is nearly as big a deal
as a lot of people have made it to be
whether they be the tabloids or they be
the fans responding to it single season
companions are not uncommon I do think
this probably was not originally planned
since we have the couple of extra
episodes in the season that follows but
since we do have those couple of extra
episodes it is unlikely that there will
be plot threads left hanging that aren't
addressed and it also probably means
that it was likely largely an amicable
decision and not one that was especially
fraud or tension filled so yeah and plus
we're learning about it earlier than
would normally be the case so that makes
things seem often weird that like oh
we're going to start the new season and
we already know she's leaving I'm like
yeah that can throw off your experience
but that's not the show's fault well I I
mean at a stretch you could argue it's a
little bit their fault by making
themselves vulnerable to that by
shooting the follow-up season so far in
advance but like
yeah that is a risk that gets run with
that but I think it's a stress to say
it's their fault that this news got
out anyways that's kind of all I have to
say about this I will have more of an
opinion when I actually see more of
Millie Gibson and I will have an opinion
on verata sethu when I see her in
whatever part she gets but I think she's
a solid actress I'll be curious to see
what the dynamic is like and as I said I
while it will be the first um TARDIS
team that is completely nonwhite I'm as
far as Dynamics go that might affect the
dynamic I don't know I'm actually more
interested in the age Dynamic um between
the two of them CU they like they're
literally the same age they were born
the same year so I I think that might be
interesting but we'll see as I said
please don't get overly dramatic and
conspiratorial with like oh here's what
here's I heard why she left like we
don't know why
so if you could not go down that rabbit
hole what are your thoughts on it drop
them down in the comments talk about it
patreon pays the bills enables me to do
this as my living even if you can't help
me out that way like share subscribe
they help but what I really want you to
remember you're
beautiful you are valid and you are
loved you are the council I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
adjourned
drum roll for my highest supporting
patrons Robin Moore Thea goddess Ela
Oliver be to roac the thing that goes
dink in the anime Ruth go of the
gazarian solitary pictures ol Rick
Bogden geek filter Linda Walters Toby
Jackson Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
fori likes the poodle Robin Powell te
love czy scrapit Angry CASRO Dave Hall
quite bearish Rosalyn Bennett pal baraba
Jole and miror G thanks so
[Music]
[Applause]
much
[Music]
w